ううっうぅうううおおおおおお
今から日本語の講座を行います
日本文学の素晴らしい文章僕は今この木老公を箱の中で書き始めている
頭からかぶるとすっぽりちょうど腰のあたりまで届く段ボールの箱の中だ
つまり今のところ箱男はこの僕自身だということでもある阿部公募
箱お得私の顔そんなに醜いん
何美しいがぬ福 c かな
シンジがお世辞を言えない男だということは誰でも知っている
船は動き出した彼は遠ざかる船から開発に手を振った
そうして岸には幸福な少女が残っ
三島由紀夫氏要塞国境の長いトンネルを抜けると雪国であった
川端康成雪国馬鹿野郎がプールに戻ってる僕はいっ
違います違うとです中村は苦しそうに冷や汗を垂らして首を振った
言ってみろ僕も検問子は彼とぞ
恥ずかしゅう南京言ってみろ
運行です
僕たちまで腹が言いたくなった
村上龍飼育していないこれが私とスプリットタンの出会い
君も新大改造してみない男の言葉に私は無意識のうちに首を縦に振っていたと金原
ひとみ
蛇にピアスフィーユと体言止めが好きな人いいねして自分がゆりから顔を離す表紙に
思わず頭
位相欄を見たら日付の星がたった一つ瞬いていた
百年はもう来ていたんだなこの時初めて気が付いた
夏目漱石夢中やビートルズストーン
ビードロストーンディランディラン
ビートルズストーンズ村上春樹すべての作品
まあこれも全部蛇足だけどにょパティ山崎麻美が自分殺すつもりらしいということが
わかったら
不思議なことに最初に感じたの恐怖でをなく
パズルがやっと解けた時にインター妙の納得だった
村上隆オーディション祖父は書斎の椅子にもたれてじっと目をつぶっていた
それから買って目を開けていった
いつかお前たちに語らなければならないと思っていた
100と直樹 a n 0情熱とは相手の立場を無視することかもしれません
太宰治
人間失格でしたを見せて
前にも言われて見せてあげたことがあったセンターターンに刺さったピアスが珍しいの
だろう
ベッドスターを出して見せてやると男の子はゲット大きな声を上げてもらったん
そうして笑う男の子を見て彼よりも good 背の低い雪が顔をくしゃくしゃにして
ゲラゲラと笑った
3人で笑っていると今日私のしたことが何だったのかすっかりわからなくなった
金原ひとみトリップトラップ幼い頃から僕はいつか自分に合ったマヨネーズにておくと
夢見ていた
と
pere
ni